sie fühlen sich falsch behandelt
ich habe immer das gefühl dass wir die
neuen gastarbeiter in deutschland sendet
ihren frust darüber lassen sie hier raus
beschäftigte des online supermarktes
gorillaz letzte woche vor der zentrale
des startups in berlin der grund für die
aufregung in der internationalen und
deshalb englisch sprechenden belegschaft
etlichen kolleginnen wurde fristlos
gekündigt
einige von uns haben einen
entlassungsschreiben bekommen andere
wurden am telefon gefeuert mit
unterdrückter nummer und bei diesen
anrufen wurde uns nicht mal ein name
gesagt es hieß nur gerufen von gorillas
an
gorillas verspricht lieferungen des
täglichen bedarfs in zehn minuten durch
ein dichtes netz an lagerhäusern und
radtouren das liefer startup ist stark
gewachsen doch jetzt kommt es zu
massiven kündigungen
damit reagiert gorillas auf wilde das
heißt nicht gewerkschaftlich
organisierte streiks wie hier hatten
beschäftigte zuletzt einige standorte
lahmgelegt
die gorillaz belegschaft ist bisher kaum
gewerkschaftlich organisiert auch ein
betriebsrat fehlt in dem jungen
unternehmen noch die alternative methode
der beschäftigten wilde streiks ist in
deutschland juristisch höchst umstritten
und wird vielfach als kündigungsgrund
gesehen doch einige kurier innen seien
wohl keinen anderen ausweg mehr
wir streiken weil die bedingungen so
schlecht sind nicht weil uns langweilig
ist oder so sondern wegen der
grundlegenden sachen die hier respektlos
gegenüber uns reihen laufen und das
obwohl diese startup schon seit einem
jahr existiert
der konflikt ist nicht neu gorillas
beschäftigte kämpfen seit monaten um
verbesserungen über ein arbeiter
kollektiv und bissige - in sozialen
medien die forderungen pünktliche
bezahlung mehr arbeitssicherheit weniger
schwere lasten auch müssten bei der
schichtplanung gesetzliche fristen und
ruhezeiten eingehalten werden
screenshots deuten an dass das nicht der
fall ist das start up das sich nur
schriftlich äußern will beteuert
als unternehmen das seine mitarbeiter
innen in den mittelpunkt stellt suchen
wir stets den konstruktiven dialog und
haben bereits viele
verbesserungsvorschläge umgesetzt
die meisten beschäftigten seien
zufrieden doch vor dem lager klingt das
anders
die leute die hier arbeiten waren
zuletzt gezwungen mehr lieferungen zu
machen mehrere pakete gleichzeitig auf
dem rücken zu tragen
manchmal müssen wir 15 20 kilogramm
tragen und damit in den fünften stock
laufen wenn wir zurückkommen tut uns der
rücken weh und wir sind fertig
wir können diesen weg nicht mehr
ertragen
einzige kleine verbesserungen hier am
standort sei ein einziges lastenrad in
der gesamten flotte und das sei auch
noch unhandlich
ein hauptgrund für die streiks ist auch
die sicherheit der räder im gefährlichen
stadtverkehr beschäftigte dokumentieren
online immer wieder lose rat komponenten
die plötzlich während der fahrt nach
geben unfälle seien keine seltenheit
der satte das teil auf dem wir sitzen
bricht einfach ab während wir fahren und
das kann den starken verkehr passieren
es ist ja nicht so dass wir hier in
einem vorort wären hier ist eine große
kreuzung 1000 autos fahren vorbei und
wenn ich dann mittendrin bin und meinen
sattel bricht muss sich entweder auf
einem metallrohr sitzen oder falle und
werde überfahren
eine ähnliche erfahrung hat neulich auch
kurier weg gemacht er habe in einer
schicht seinen vorgesetzten auf den
lenker eines rades angesprochen
ich habe ihm gesagt dass mir das fahrrad
an lenker und bremsen unsicher vorkommt
und ich damit mich weiter ausliefern
will er hat daran herumgewerkelt und
dann gesagt das ist alles gut du kannst
los und dann bei der nächsten oder
übernächsten lieferung hatte ich dem
unfall eine halbe stunde nachdem ich
mich über das rad beschwert hatte
gorillas versichert uns auf anfrage zu
den rädern zunächst möchten wir noch
einmal betonen dass die sicherheit
unserer reiter für uns oberste priorität
hat wir haben einen genauen ablauf für
die tägliche überprüfung der e-bikes
eingeführt und achten auf die einhaltung
strenger sicherheitsmaßnahmen unsere
kräfte sparenden e bikes werden täglich
kontrolliert die strecken den reiter
finden die bisherigen maßnahmen jedoch
unzureichend und fordern mehr solche
konflikte sind für liefer startups nicht
ungewöhnlich meinen fachleute
[Musik]
also in der form dass sie einfach
überhaupt nicht auf der agenda der
plattform stehen das heißt die
beschäftigten müssen sich das wirklich
alles und jedes minimale punkt an
arbeits und gesundheitsschutz selber
erkämpft allerdings gorillas sieht sich
explizit nicht in dieser linie das
startup betont ist stelle die meisten
beschäftigten fest an zahle mit zehn
euro 50 je stunde über mindestlohn und
halte sich an regeln die wilden streiks
hingegen seien unzulässig und man habe
durchgreifen müssen das bedeutet dass
wir das arbeitsverhältnis mit denjenigen
mitarbeiter in beenden die sich aktiv an
den nicht genehmigten streiks und
blockaden beteiligt den betrieb durch
ihr verhalten behindert und ihre
kolleginnen damit gefährdet haben
klar ist ständige unkontrollierte
streiks sind für ein junges unternehmen
auf dauer eine große gefahr diese
beenden zu wollen scheint deshalb
erstmal nachvollziehbar
beschäftigte beklagen allerdings das
management habe zunächst zugesagt mit
ihnen über ihre forderungen zu sprechen
doch
statt diese probleme anzuerkennen und
mit uns nach lösungen zu suchen haben
sie sich für den härtesten weg
entschieden und setzen die leute einen
nach dem anderen vor die tür
einige beschäftigte wollen nun die
kündigungen anfechten eine möglichkeit
könnten formfehler darin sein doch sie
wollen auch klarheit über die frage
fordern sind wilde streiks zulässig
sie werfen uns vor illegale streiks
gemacht zu haben und ich will klären
lassen dass das was wir getan haben
nicht illegal war
ich will dass vor gericht bringen und
einen präzedenzfall schaffen auch für
andere menschen und andere arbeitskämpfe
das wilde selbstorganisierte streiks
nicht illegal sind
bisher dominiert in deutschland die
richterliche auslegung dass nur
gewerkschaftlich organisierte streiks
legitim sein der renommierte
arbeitsrechtler wolfgang däubler betont
jedoch unter berufung auf
völkerrechtliche verträge die
deutschland ratifiziert hat gelte
dass die europäische sozialcharta
auch das streikrecht einzelner
garantiert ohne dass deshalb die
gewerkschaft intervenieren muss das kann
aber bedeuten dass also einzelne richter
sehr wohl auf die idee kochen zu sagen
wir müssen das deutsche ungeschriebene
arbeitskampfrecht müssen wir so auslegen
dass es in übereinstimmung mit dem
völkerrecht hier mit der europäischen
sozialcharta und dann würde man die
spontanen arbeitsniederlegung die
sogenannte streik für grundsätzlich
legal als laut dobler können
beschäftigte aus einem weiteren grund
die arbeit verweigern auch ohne
gewerkschaft nämlich wenn der
arbeitgeber vorschriften bricht
die löhne würden nicht bezahlt also
halte ich meine arbeitsleistung zu oder
die bedingungen verstoßen gegen
arbeitsschutzrecht weil die gesundheit
ist gefährdet dann kann ich meine
arbeitsleistung zurück das ist ein
zurückbehaltungsrecht
dass auch kollektiv ausgeübt werden kann
ob ein gericht die grundsatzfragen über
wilde streiks an gehen wird ist offen
für die klassischen gewerkschaften
brächte das neue fragestellungen mit
sich werden sie dann überhaupt noch
gebraucht bei verdi wo man erst langsam
kontakt zu den eher anarchisch
organisierten gorillaz beschäftigten
aufbaut schwertmann weiter auf bewährte
mittel
wir unterstützen im augenblick die
bildung eines betriebsrates wir
empfehlen den beschäftigten dieses
möglichst schnell vorzunehmen weil so
kann konkret hilfe geleistet werden im
unternehmens können die probleme die
kündigung einzelner beschäftigter
beispielsweise nicht vorhandene oder
kaputte arbeitsmittel verspätete
lohnzahlung solche probleme können
angegangen werden parallel zur baldigen
betriebsratswahl wollen einige
beschäftigte jedoch offenbar weiter auch
wild rebellieren gegen das aus ihrer
sicht rücksichtslose geschäftsgebaren
mit so viel widerstand hat das start-up
in seiner strategie wohl nicht gerechnet
die beschäftigten wollen nicht nur
arbeiten sondern auch die
unternehmenspolitik verändern noch ist
unklar wie das kräftemessen ausgeht doch
das beispiel zeigt schnelles wachstum
könnte für startups künftig schwieriger
werden wenn die beschäftigten nicht mehr
ziehen